hello everyone Karen warden with film
courage the radio show were here with
film finance expert Jeff steel of film
closings calm everybody and film closing
zinc and we had a question come in from
miles maker filmmaker from New York City
that we didn't get to during the show
and he asked you know Jeff you're used
to working with big budgets and and
people with proven track records but
what about individuals who have poor
credit or no proven track record are
their venture capitalists out there who
are willing to take a chance on these
individuals does it just depend on how
great the project is or someone doesn't
look good on paper then basically
there's no chance that someone bigger
will take a risk on them it actually
goes both ways miles and hello miles and
thank you for all the comments on my
site the venture capitalists per se as
institutional financers no they're not
going to take a risk on on producers
that have little to no credits I assume
that's what you mean by credits are not
a microcredit store unfortunately I've
never seen a credit check on our indie
producer before so here in luck but as
far as institutional investors like
venture capitalists and funds and things
like that no they're generally not going
to take a risk on unproven producers
because they are financing other
people's money and they have to be
responsible and they have to be good
stewards of that money and if the film
flops and the investment goes away then
they need to be able to turn around and
look their investors in the eye and say
yes this was a good investment and it's
hard to say that convincingly if the
person is unproven that said certainly
there are financed ears as high net
individuals who take chances on
independent film financier independent
producers in the low budget range you'll
find them as individual high net people
you'll find them as investing groups the
proverbial anesthesiologists and
dentists and things like that but there
are rich people in every city and every
town in the country la is pretty tapped
out New York certainly has a lot more so
I would certainly recommend looking
outside of La New York Chicago and
focusing on the rest of the country
where there is a tremendous deal of
wealth and and a lot fewer opportunities
to invest it especially in something
like film which has currently considered
the the the best high-risk investments
since real estate is all over the place
and the stock market is unpredictable
and fine artists is also having a
problem so film is kind of new forest
gump have defaulted its way up to the to
the top of the pile and it's obviously
sexier and when these people are sitting
around dinner parties they would rather
tell their friends that they've invested
in a film at another strip hall so you
have to just go out and find these
people and it's a lot of pounding the
pavement a lot of doing that dog and
pony show which has a producer I'm sure
you're very well aware well going back
to real estate for a moment you had put
in a blog post that ass goes the I
believe was commercial real estate
market so goes film and i know it
stirred up a lot of debate on your site
because people were saying well with
real estate market you can kind of
accurately predict to some extent how
things are going to go with market
trends and you know interest rates and
different things whereas a film you
don't know what the audience will
respond to so i'm curious where that
analogy comes into play that as goes the
real estate market so goes film it comes
into play it's there's certainly no
quantifiable evidence this is me over 10
to 15 years of just seeing the to you
know move in the same waves coming in
out of Hollywood and my feeling on that
comes from that certainly when you're
dealing with larger investors and again
with institutional investors like hedge
funds these kinds of funds and these
kinds of investors even family offices
would much rather write a fewer amount
of really big checks and lots of little
chance and that's one of the other
reasons that lower lower budget films
aren't as popular with them because
there's a lot of legal there's a lot of
work that goes into bringing together
and closing a deal so you want the
return on that to be as big as possible
and you want it to be worth all that
time and effort cost that goes into it
and a smaller project can't really bear
those costs whereas big projects can
real estate or big projects and films
with big projects when you're getting in
excess of 10 million and that's why I've
seen when when capital becomes available
in the markets the people who have that
which would get would be like the hedge
funds and the equity funds and you know
they want to deploy it they don't want
it sitting idle and they'd like to write
bigger check some smaller checks and
there aren't a lot of places where you
can write really big checks in one fell
swoop and real estate happens to be one
and film happens to be the other and
that's the correlation that I've always
seen between the two in in the recent i
would say four to six years i've also
seen a lot of real estate developers
segue into film finance guys like
michael benaroya and people like that
are coming out of the the commercial
real estate world and the the
transactions how the production line is
financed is actually very similar almost
identical to a commercial real estate
loan and again commercial reels of
commercial real estate developers they
like film because the use of the big
numbers they're not threatened by all
those commas and zeros and the in the
financing structure the same way you've
got you've got an equity piece sitting
on the bottom and you got a bank
sitting on the top both of them have tax
credits some of real estate it's low
income housing credits and green credits
and things like that in film it's the
state tax credits obviously you're not
pre-selling foreign territories and a
real estate transaction but you know the
the overall structure is very similar so
a lot of these developers can actually
use the same people who are using in
real estate to put together their their
film finance packages and and they're
used to the structure and dealing with
the government's and everybody else so
they kind of feel right at home so again
that's one of the other correlations and
so if a developer is investing in film
that he's obviously doing well which
means the real estate market is doing
well therefore you know by by the
trickle-down theory you know film ends
up doing well as well because that's
where they start deploying their money
and they're not deploying it as an
institution like the development company
they're deploying it as an individual
which goes back to my earlier comment
about it's the individuals that
producers lower budget producers would
look to as opposed to the institutions